the next thing i say may be mind-blowing  to you the tide doesn't actually come in  and out  there is a  bulge of water two of them on opposite  sides of the earth caused by the sun and  the moon and earth turns  inside that bulge when we say the water  rises and falls tidally what's happening  is we are rotating into the bulge and  then out of the bulge so the bulge is  already already there and all we kind of  do is pass through the pass through and  the water gets high and it gets low so  we're stuck with language from our own  perspective rather than language of  what's actually happening simpler that  way to say the water goes in and out  it's simpler to say the sun set rather  than earth rotated such that our angle  of view on the stationary sun fell below  our local horizon